scottie pippen uh played a few years
less than michael jordan was his
teammate and ended up making more than
him during his career scottie pippen got
paid more money than michael jordan as a
salary yeah there's probably 150 200 nba
players that have now made more than
michael jordan yeah but his own teammate
that played in the same era yeah he
switched teams and whatever but yes
during his same era he played less years
than michael jordan actually did and he
made more money
joe what's up what's going on how are
you good yeah yeah are you ready to do
this let's do it all right what are you
going to teach us today we're going to
talk about michael jordan all right goat
goat yeah is he the greatest of all time
uh probably i don't you know there's an
argument but uh probably yes
and uh but he's also an incredible
businessman all right he turned 94
million dollars in salary into two and a
half billion dollars net worth today so
he got paid 94 million throughout his
entire playing career
so we'll run through it but he he is the
richest athlete of all time he's got the
highest net worth of any athlete in
history
and most people don't know this but it's
really been through two business deals
two business deals in particular he's
done a bunch of them but two of them
have really uh made up probably 95
percent of that net worth
so the story is that michael jordan was
an incredible college basketball player
right he went to unc uh he won a
national championship there he was the
national player of the year he was
drafted third overall i believe in 1984
that draft pick and he went to the
chicago bulls so he was paid well uh
players weren't paid though what they
are today back then so throughout his
entire career we have a chart here that
pulls up his estimated earnings and he
made between 550k to 4 million dollars
for 13 years out of the 15 years he
played so if you look at the chart
between 1996 and 1998 there was two
outliers there right he made 30 million
dollars and then 33 million dollars
everything else is between 500k and 4
million
so there was a loophole that the chicago
bulls were able to exploit there that
allowed them to pay him
more and probably closer to his fair
market value but relatively speaking 94
million is a lot of money of course uh
but but relatively speaking he was
underpaid compared to other players so
for example pippin uh played a few years
less than michael jordan was his
teammate and ended up making more than
him during his career scottie pippen got
paid more money than michael jordan as a
salary yeah that's a wild stat
throughout his entire career i mean he's
not the only one there's like 100 i mean
salaries have changed of course now but
there's probably 150 200 nba players
that have now made more than michael
jordan yeah but his own teammate that
played in the same era yeah he switched
teams and whatever but yes during his
same era he played less years than
michael jordan actually did and he made
more money so he was relatively
underpaid just kind of how the contracts
worked out and whatever made 93 million
a lot of money of course but but
underpaid
and the reason why he's been able to
turn that into 2.5 billion when people
who haven't made or who have made much
more than him weren't able to do that is
through two deals so i think most people
know about nike by now
the main kind of story of it yeah and
well the main summary of the story with
his with him and nike
is that uh
he wanted to wear a converse or adidas
out of college so he wore converse in
college dean smith was the coach at unc
at the time he was getting paid about
ten thousand dollars a year by converse
to have his players wear converse okay
so there was no nip back then yeah dean
smith is getting paid 10k to tell his
players to wear a conversation okay so
as the coach unc converse is paying him
to tell the players so he wore converse
in college all the unc players did when
he graduated he wanted to go to adidas
he was like i love the three stripes
supposedly and adidas didn't want him
though they had just done a change of
ownership one of the previous owners had
passed away and they were kind of going
through some things and they didn't want
to do any of the business deals so
adidas said no
so they went to converse converse
offered them
essentially what amounted to like a
hundred thousand dollars per year which
was on par with all the other players
were making
michael j uh uh uh johnson magic johnson
sorry yeah and all the other guys
converse had all of them and they were
paying them roughly all the same they
offered the same exact deal to michael
jordan michael jordan asked them
reportedly uh what are you going to do
with me that's different and then i know
we're going to treat you just like
everyone else and they thought that was
a compliment right for a rookie coming
in the league yeah we're going to treat
you just like magic johnson everyone
else he didn't like that of course being
michael jordan uh and totally they
didn't know go back to adidas like let's
find a way to make that work agent told
him dude adidas is not happening not
gonna happen whatever nike uh nike was
becoming popular around this time period
in the 1980s but they were actually
going through some financial trouble
they had just reported their first
quarterly loss ever and they were losing
market share to some of the other
companies so they were kind of hitting
this gross plateau at the time and they
were looking for big name athletes the
way nike made its brand where they were
basically just going out and throwing
piles of money at all these athletes to
sponsor their products so they were
looking to do that with michael jordan
too jordan wasn't interested essentially
at first his agent told him dude get on
the plane go visit the campus he said no
his mom supposedly said get on the plane
go he went they offered him five times
as much money so 500k a year uh over
five years so two and a half million
dollars which was roughly equivalent to
his nba contract at the time and much
more than any other nba player was
making to be the face of nike basketball
essentially and that nike basketball was
non-existent at the time so uh it was
kind of like an outlier today offering a
big contract to someone and you just
don't really know but they gave him the
ability to
um
to build his own brand they were like
hey we're gonna build clothing we're
gonna build all this other merchandise
and you're really going to have the
jordan brand it wasn't that at first but
that's what they detailed they would get
to eventually so
he ends up accepting the deal
which was an outlier given everyone
else's contract and i think the story is
that nike so they did the air jordan one
which was the first version of his shoe
and i think they believed that it would
sell it he had to sell i think it was a
million dollars uh yeah they estimated
they would bring in three million
dollars in sales over the first three
years so a million dollars a year for
the first three years they wanted it to
sell and there was clauses in the
contract where if he didn't get it maybe
they broke the deal if they didn't get
it maybe they increased the money
and instead of three million dollars
over three years he did 125 million
dollars in year one
yeah literally 125 million in the first
year the shoes just blew up i mean he
was very very good obviously uh but
there's a there's a story that the shoe
was banned by the nba nike said wear it
anyways because of the colors and they
paid the fine for every game so it
became kind of like this cultural thing
but then he just became a star right so
he blew up and and he ends up
renegotiating that deal with mikey
eventually where today he gets five
percent royalty on all jordan brand
sales so right off the top of revenue he
gets five percent of every single dollar
spent plus or minus yeah on everything
for the jordan brand itself yeah that is
a wild number yeah are you ready for
this yeah they did 4.7 billion dollars
of sales last year he got 150 million
dollars of money from nike last year
holy [ __ ] he hasn't played in decades
and he's still the most the highest paid
player in basketball
literally jordan durant all these guys
he makes way more than them and we have
a chart here actually the signature
shoes where it shows how much he made
this is a few years old at this point i
think it's it's 20 20.
but so jordan from nike from the jordan
brand made 130 million dollars that year
the next closest was lebron who made 32
million then 26 2016 et cetera so he
makes you know a multiple five times or
so more than lebron or duran or anyone
else even though he hasn't played in
years yeah it's all because of the
revenue and the deal he was able to
negotiate off of that well it also
became a cultural thing right it was
like where they had their retro ones
it's a whole brand now they do golf they
do everything now and that's actually
what's really exploded it so if you uh
we have another chart here that shows
his his annual income over time from
forbes it's kind of this uh uh it shows
like this peak in a valley right so the
first bump is when he retired and then
it goes up because basically what nike
did is they started accelerating the
jordan brand and now they're doing at
first they did this whole thing where
they were limiting the quantity of goods
out there through a scarcity model and
now they're allowing all of it out there
and you can see it's just blown up he
went from making about 40 million or 35
million dollars a year after retirement
and now he's making close to 150 or 160
million dollars a year absolutely insane
and the majority of that income is now
coming through his nike deal right he he
doesn't necessarily earn cash flow from
a bunch of other things it's really just
the nike deal but that has awarded him
hundreds of millions of dollars in cash
and probably billions of dollars of cash
at this point but the second best
business deal he probably did was the
nba team right so he acquired the uh
what were the charlotte bobcats at the
time now the charlotte hornets in 2010
he paid bob johnson who previously on
the team 180 million dollars for 97
percent of the franchise 20 10
180 yep 180 in 2010 uh for for 97
percent of the franchise okay and anyone
who ever has ever seen a chart and i
think we have it also but franchise
valuations blew up yeah and the media
and the media rights were the main
reason for that the nba negotiated these
media rights over the last decade that
have really tremendously increased the
value of these franchises so if you look
at 2010 he paid like 100 it was 180 at
the time so well below what they
actually had valued at he comes in and
now the franchise is worth 1.6 billion
dollars wow 10 to almost 10 times his
money in the span of a decade
essentially so that that compromises the
most of his of the other amount of
income on his net worth he sold a part
of it at a slightly lower valuation
probably 1.4 1.5 a few years ago he
still is the majority owner of the team
though and the the the team's valuation
has increased dramatically yeah and the
idea here is that they're only going to
continue to increase over time because
the media rights will continue to get
larger and larger
uh the sport becomes more global in
nature and uh there's this like weird
synergy uh between as the nba becomes
more popular michael jordan becomes more
popular michael jordan becomes more
popular the shoes become more popular
and he just keeps just baking yeah well
nike too if you look at so yes i agree
with that there's a few different things
i think when it comes to nike like that
amount of money is only going to get
bigger they've really just now started
to press the gas a little bit on
actually expanding that product line so
they used to literally just do shoes
then maybe they were doing a little bit
of clothing now they're expanding to
ancillary categories right now they're
making women's clothing now they're
making golf clothing they're starting to
sponsor college football teams they're
starting to sponsor pro golfers et
cetera so i think uh his percentage is
fixed right so that as that business
continues to grow his annual income is
going to continue to grow and then i
think the other thing to look at is yeah
the nba team the nba team i don't think
has hit anywhere near its ceiling when
it comes to evaluation perspective
there's a bunch of things in my mind and
i've talked about this plenty of things
that i think are going to propel the
valuation higher and a lot of that
revolves around
a few things in particular one is
streaming rights so i think that the nba
has drastically increased i know they've
drastically increased their media rights
over the last decade or two but
ultimately
linear television the only thing holding
it together is sports is live sports if
you look at the broadcast ratings last
year 95 out of the top 100 most viewed
broadcasts of last year on cable tv were
live sports so sports are the only thing
holding this up and maybe some news
along with it but ultimately what we're
going to see is as that starts to
decline and less people have cable and
more streaming services come up they're
going to start paying a lot more money
so if the if the supply is fixed and the
demand increases the price of these
assets are going to continue to rise i
think that's important and then i think
sports betting is another massive uh
massive tailwind that are going to
propel these valuations higher we
haven't even hit i don't even know if 10
15 of what we'll see from like a total
dollar amount and these leagues and
these individual teams are going to
benefit tremendously from that yeah uh
and jordan just continues to pull in
five percent of all jordan brand sales
as income and then he's got the team
which really is equity value more so
than anything else just a little bit of
financial performance uh has he done
anything else that you're just like wow
this is like bonkers uh that he's bought
or owns so he he's got a lot of other
stuff going on he has uh equity in a
bunch of tech companies he owns a part
of an e-sports team he owns a liquor
company a tequila company um he owns a
couple auto dealerships uh he had a
small stake in miami marlins i don't
know if he he he bought it with derek
jeter when when derek jeter bought in
dare jesus sold his so i don't know if
that included his uh but he had some
exposure to major league baseball and
then he actually joined draftking's
board of directors
so i don't know if he uh because of his
basketball prowess or his uh gambling uh
uh experience probably a little bit of
both
they're like this guy is a perfect
marketing uh tool for us
but yeah i mean he's got connections in
the nba right he's obviously a big brand
he can help from like a strategic
standpoint also so i think when it comes
down to that like he'll make plenty of
money on other stuff too just because of
who he is and the brand that he's built
but ultimately like to have two deals
alone that make you billions of dollars
from your career now when you look back
on it they say his net worth is two and
a half billion dollars it's probably
ultimately more than that given what
he's done with nike and what the team
has done also in his equity ownership in
there but he made 94 million dollars
that's less than five percent of his
total net worth now came from nba
earnings that's crazy well he also
pioneered this whole idea of while
you're playing build the brand get the
brand to then set up the businesses own
either uh revenue streams off of the
businesses or own the equity of the
businesses and then uh when you're done
playing you use your cur your playing
career really is just like a launch pad
for your businesses and he you know
probably more so than anyone else uh did
that to perfection there's you know shaq
and some and magic johnson etcetera they
own a lot of like franchises and other
things and maybe their star power in the
leagues helped them get access to that
or or strike special deals but nobody i
don't think did it like he did maybe
like greg norman right in golf or
something but nowhere near the scale at
which uh jordan has done yeah i think
he's probably the blueprint for from a
licensing perspective for sure because
if you think about back in the day too
this was this didn't happen right they
were all doing essentially cash
endorsement deals you would go sponsor
gatorade would pay you some cash uh you
know any of these brands coca-cola
whatever they would pay you money to
basically go advertise and let them use
your name image and likeness in
commercials and that's really what it
was and that's what he did a lot at
first too but then he got this deal with
nike and nike really it benefited both
them tremendously right nike blew up in
and kind of brand value and attention
from when they first signed the deal
with jordan and it's propelled their
basketball division now it's the most
important basketball division in the
world for any company so you see plenty
of players wearing nike shoes here but
georgian shoes in particular during the
nba season it's obviously a big youth
movement but the other thing to think
about too is like this isn't even
necessarily just about basketball
performance anymore right to your point
he's built an incredible brand because
the actual basketball shoes are a very
small percentage of nike's overall sales
right it's the clothing it's the
ancillary businesses that they've been
able to build off of the jordan brand
that aren't necessarily performance
related right there's only so many
basketball shoes you can sell it's
really everything that comes off of that
and they've turned his line into this
kind of cultural movement where everyone
wants the retro shoes everyone wants all
the older stuff uh and it's really
different from anything else out there
today all right i got two questions that
we got to go first is uh yo mars was it
the shoes
right and that's iconic commercial not
only were the shoes a huge part of this
but also just the way that they market
it the way that they built him into a
cultural uh phenomena was was a huge
piece of why he's so successful yeah for
sure all right second thing is where can
we send people to find you on the
internet
you can uh go to the newsletter read
huddle up dot com every morning monday
through friday newsletter goes out on a
sports business topic read huddle up dot
com and then uh the podcast the joe pomp
show on apple spotify youtube etc go
check it out all right and then uh
before uh we have john come in here uh
what what is gonna be your criteria for
finding topics cause i just learned a
lot of stuff like the wildest thing you
just told us was that scottie pippen
played less seasons but made more in
lifetime earnings than jordan what is
going to be the criteria for the topics
you picked to come in and uh teach us if
i think it's interesting i'll share it
all right i like that
i feel like a lot of people are
interested in things i'm interested in
too you know sports is that because
they're interested in things you're
interested in or is it because you're
interested in things they're interested
in both oh so i just feel like there's a
lot of similar interests you know like
people want to hear about exactly the
stat you just mentioned they want to
hear about how he gets a five percent
royalty i'm sure a lot of people don't
know that yeah i didn't know that
exactly so if i find it interesting i'll
share it all right that's fine that
that's uh uh oh john wants you to talk
about your baseball career
we don't need to say anything about that
that tells you all you need to do
hey it's all right it's fine uh all
right thanks for coming uh to do this
we'll see you uh tomorrow sounds good
better bring a good uh topic i will all
right we'll see